[Applaudissements]
et c'est parti pour le conseil de classe
2 doc gynéco un élève qui brille
davantage par ses silences que par ses
interventions que celle les bogdanoff
sont capables de décrypter rire noble
qu'est ce t'en penses tout cas sympa tu
sais j'ai rien compris à qui tu penses
de lui attend j'appelle roger hanin
parce qu'il pardonne pas non mais sinon
oui des animaux doc
non mais j'écoute de la bonne musique
chaque c'est l'élève gynéco qui a été
observé à plusieurs reprises en train de
consommer une potion magique qui ne
semble rien arranger à la pertinence de
ces interventions tout cas su bois l'a
d'ailleurs assez du jus de cassis bon
bah c'est pas bon verre alors mais
malgré ces interventions plutôt étrange
doc est un élément fils et apporter de
la bonne humeur au reste de la classe
notamment grâce à ces fous rires plus ou
moins justifiées pas de possibles
la femelle du lévrier httt au ps c'est
la révélation doc est le meilleur
sportif de la classe alors qu'elle note
pour doc gynéco christine kelly vas-y
alors dominé qu il a planté le plus
grand des rappeurs mondiaux dr dre au
studio et il n'a jamais planté anona au
studio à un point où il a planté dr dre
il y aurait donc des docks tonnes c'est
vrai que vous avez peut-être planté dr
d'un des plus grands orateurs avoir
volonté à leurs noms mais je ne fais pas
payer non sur un studio à los angeles
dans ses studios à laramie studio il ya
une rumeur comme ça qui est sorti en
commun que c'est vrai de faire semblant
je connais les dossiers il a il a
produit 6 4 2 enfin le mec il est calme
on connaît de nombreux états en tout cas
n'a jamais planté par une seule fois
donc ça c'est un très bon pouvoir ici
perfectionniste il se réveille tous les
matins à 7 heures première action
il se rendort après t'inquiète jusqu'à
17h première action ils regardent
l'émission de la veille des missions tpm
paix d'henri points et prend des notes
non ce sont des notes qui prend pour
tout ça je lui dis non à l'extension des
notes en quelle année
son défaut c'est qu'il ne s'est pas
tranché pour ne froisser personne
avec ça quitte à se mettre dans
l'embarras quitte à porter à se mettre
dans de sales draps c'est le cas en ce
moment avec voilà il n'a pas voulu trop
accabler christine angot et en lion veut
alors voilà il porte sur le dos valent à
l'instar de tout le monde alors que
c'est tout un tout gentil on l'est on
adore et cette série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leurs deux de leurs marais doc je
connaissais le rappeur j'ai appris à
connaître le glandeur l'homme qui est
gentil et qui voit toujours la bouteille
à moitié vide comme on dit un petit peu
ce problème c'est pas un scoop
pas une parole page chiffres rien et
pourtant tu es devenu une des stars de
l'émission assez formidable sans parler
il ya des émissions où j'étais inquiet
j'ai donc été empaillé et là tu bouges
plus tu je sais pas si tu étais là ou
pas et tu fais partie de ces gens et des
gens font ça me paraît beaucoup de faire
beaucoup de bruit pour exister toit a
comme toi toi qui parle très peu mon
chou mais quand tu parles c'est juste ma
sérieusement c'est souvent très bien vu
avec beaucoup de poésie
alors c'est que tu connais absolument
rien en média bon ça c'est parce qu'on
te demande mais en revanche la
télévision ce n'est pas que c'est aussi
la télévision c'est aussi vecteur
d'émotions et franchement pour le coup
tu véhicule beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'émissions de d'émotion c'est parce que
les gens adorent et moi le premier et
donc je t'ai mis huit sur dix parce que
franchement
je dirais que la force de cyril et c'est
pas c'est pas moi dans ma tête en tout
cas mon mec pour rien la force de cyril
dans ma tête
j'espère un jour ailleurs mais bon sens
et nommé retraite et c'est pas un mec
c'est qu'il voit chez jean cot ya un
potentiel quand on t'a vu arriver tu
lisais pas un mot comment ce mec a pu se
dire je vais faire de lui une vedette de
la télé et il l'a fait et franchement
bravo
là il fait partie de la famille se
tiendra pas il va faire trois cadenas
nasa et andrey agrémenter un vrai
personne lightman d'une grande
profondeur d'autres il est très
intelligent vraiment jolie et comme je
recueille depuis longtemps je le sais je
sais ce qu'il vaut moi et il sait que
jolène forsythe mais vous comme tu
arrives à trouver avoir cédé jean pardon
mais même face et tout le monde à voir
ce que tu vas pouvoir sortir d'une
personne ne tire la pelote de laine et
tu fais un chroniqueur témoin idéal bbh
guillamot sais pas c'était pas les
renards à mes honnorat baby i'm here
habib sy s'est chichement sabata note
bon j'ai dit oui tu suis un peu
l'activité dont il estime qu'elle dit
j'aime bien mais elle est chaude et
docks
réveille toi tu aimes ou tu es l'ont tué
endormi tué à l'ong y tuer nonchalant
pour moitié entre t'choupi et winnie
l'ourson en peluche en fait de doudou et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que tu es ici
en fait comme dans un énorme plus m'a en
fait parfois honte réveil mais ce qui
est extraordinaire chez toi c'est qu'en
fait mater lunaire t perché tempête au
bonnet et tu as une sorte de atterrir
c'est pas des punchline poétique
je pense comme moi vraiment est la
meilleure recrue de tpm paix depuis nom
mathieu n'en depuis benjamin castaldi
depuis trois ans était exceptionnel
vraiment tu déchires je t'admire
beaucoup et je te mets un magnifique 2
[Musique]
parce qu'au niveau des médias c'est
léger quand même assez d'hôtesses et
notre pire menace c'est pas bien c'est
la 22e son bail je vais aller mamie oh
non j'ai les coûts est une révélation il
semble même temps la vôtre parce que
c'est vrai qu'alors je n'aurais pas misé
un iota dessus donc la bonne note et
pour vous deux que je vais m et pour
vous deux et c'est vrai que c'est une
peluche vous savez c'est comme les
peluches dans les grands magasins les
enfants ont fait un calinous avec ta
trempe son peloton se disent intéressés
bis et winnie l'ourson
il est génial je me mélange à côté de
lui ça rien faire boum boum le nom de
gynéco on oublie et donc c'est pour ça
que moi les peluches on aime mieux on
n'aime pas en mai et 0 on adore on me
dise et donc moi je mets 10 voulais
partager cet effort parce qu'il a tout
compris l'ademe tpm pc quoi les gens
viennent regarder tp pour le
divertissement et pour se distraire et
pour se relâcher et se marrer il a tout
compris il est naturel il est son
plateau comme une horloge il nous fait
beaucoup rire en loge la grande race
track quand on l'a vu
devant la police on a vu l'amitié quand
il vous a pas balancer la gentillesse et
l'amitié
il a pour moi il a vraiment vraiment
tout compris il est bienveillant je te
mets 7,5 monde loc 9
benjamin castaldi vous le voyez d'autres
[Rires]
séries dans les yeux très petit nom ça
va c'est bon j'ai rendez vous le 20 je
voulais dire le 20 janvier rendez vous
le prouver
à cause de vous je m'attend j'ai un vrai
complexe non je vais refaire tout je
sais tout et pour avoir fait tout ce que
vous n'êtes pas de vrais débats de
monnaies voulez mais ça ne vous dira pas
méchant j'ai toujours aimé gbagbo comme
ça c'est tout moi j'adore voir ce que
voit pas ça va casser à dix pendant
l'émission bien entendu voilà dans les
pages à la napoule et jure ne fait rien
voilà très beau comme ça tu as dis à ta
femme
oui le sait bien sur quoi elle a dit on
leur remet tout mais ça va durer oui non
cvs tour offert enfin j'en suis là des
petits d'y conduire dans cinq ans on est
aveugle
chaque année ça
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois je suis venu chercher
en camionnette ils m'appellent smart
[Rires]
je suis allé chez lui il m'a dit je vais
prendre en main il avait prendre hamma
dans un pdf
il n'a plus la guinée ne voit plus rien
il après il a énormément mais il arrive
le monde et propose quoi oui oui alors
donc
donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué
de me donner note en tant que
chroniqueur médias parce que c'est vrai
que tu es un homme extraordinaire tes
impôts être fabuleux tac profondeur
doivent incroyable tu es un amour tu
étais mon frère mais si je m'en réfère
ou qu'elle est et qu'on devrait attendre
d'un chroniqueur médias
tu n'as aucune des qualités requises
c'est ça fait ça fait longtemps qu'on a
pas parlé mais je me rends réfère à
catane 1 0 donc en conséquence de quoi
en conséquence de quoi
soit je m'étais dit ce soit je m'étais 0
et en fait pas par respect pour tous ses
chroniqueurs disparu trop tôt qui
travaille beaucoup je sais qu'à des
coeurs dont l'histoire est trop tôt
keane qui travaille beaucoup mais qui
n'avait aucun talent je te mets 0
[Musique]
bernard montiel tamis 0 aller 1 2 on
laisse la parole à celui qui a insulté
ma mère c'est le thé bon ton pour moi on
a parlé de winnie l'ourson moi c'est
plutôt aussi un panda parce que tu es on
a envie de t'attraper de t'embrasser de
temps à ces mêmes vraiment et pas au
delà
je ressors aussi un koala c'est à dire
le côté paresseux et ce cas touchant
chez toi c'est que tu as une
bienveillance extraordinaire et la
bienveillance et comme le nectar de
l'âme qui vivre l'amour voilà donc tu es
un mec formidable c'est un bonheur de te
connaître et je crois effectivement
qu'il est le meilleur chroniqueur ici et
je t'ai mis c'est parce que 10 c'est
vrai qu'au niveau médias c'est difficile
mais cette wii pro cette édition delta
spirit cyril m'a repéré mais je n'étais
pas aperçu moi même de quoi que ce soit
a proposé de venir et je ne pensais pas
rester longtemps je sais pas si j'allais
à comprendre un jour le métier c'est
qu'il garde toujours son poids des je ne
pense pas être le meilleur même si je
l'étais je ne dirais pas faim oui j'ai
un peu de j'ai un peu de via un côté
comme ça un peu nounours mais au bond
entre nous il ya quelque chose de
particulier
merde et toi je suis étonné de quoi de
ta connerie vraiment je pense l inverse
active epa nous on passe à penser quoi
non je pensais que darnis narcissa les
narcisses et alors pas ah ouais même
mois alors c'est toi le meilleur
allez kelly très vite monsieur alors
monde actu mon dos qui tuerie aussi fort
que moi tu sais écrire en hiéroglyphes
et on a le même meilleur ami imaginaire
oui pour ça ça nous fait beaucoup de
points communs et moi je t'aime et tu le
sais donc je te mets un 10 sur 10
je dis attention méfiez-vous de l'eau
qui dort
si je sais vous allez dire des risques
mais ça c'est une émission c'est vrai
d'un lieu commun tout ma mère que vous
êtes
[Applaudissements]
je raconte un truc au télescope est
maintenant je suis en régie chez en
régime et je vois [ __ ] image chaque
fois qu'il fait et je vous rappelle que
vous êtes le 5e chrono là je dis arrêtez
moi cette émission arrêtez moi mettez
moi mais tu es mon autre chose quand je
dis méfiez-vous de l'eau qui dort parce
qu'effectivement on a on a le sentiment
comme ça que je ne sais pas ce qu'il
fout là on a le sentiment que il ne sait
pas ce qui se passe autour d'eux de du
plateau qu'il ne sait pas qui nous
sommes les uns et des autres alors qu'il
a des fulgurances alors qu'il est un
poète parfait et que il sait exactement
où il est et ce qu'il doit dire et
comment il a envie de le dire simplement
il le dit à sa façon avec des fleurs et
des poèmes et voilà et attention
attention parce que ce garçon est un
prince charmant à séducteur toutes les
filles sont folles de lui et pour toutes
ces raisons je dis
voilà voulez-vous voir d'autres
là